this is good day las vegas  good morning everybody so glad you're  with us on this tuesday i'm alex beckett  and i'm sheri swensk and i'm nathan todd  john langler has the day off today and  alex and sherry were trying to get fired  up for the golden knights playing later  tonight up in the edmonton bubble go  knights go  go nights go i love the tynate that is  so exciting  i also am excited because in a couple of  years from now nate you can wear that  ty got you with the horse on it for the  silver knights yay  well see there you go there you go  they'll be playing right i mean  i guys maybe in a couple of years  everybody will be playing again  on a normal